Game of politics for many decades has
been played as one in which you're
supposed to keep your head down.
You're supposed to be bland,
you're supposed to be uncontroversial,
your job is to court as many people as
you can.
In the middle.
Donald trump,
from the very beginning,
took a different posture.
Everything he did was about unleashing
the agency of a small number of intense
support.
So this was going to be a campaign in
which you could unleash the things that
you'd been thinking,
maybe you're mad uncle monitoring at the
television,
um,
and suddenly every mat,
uncle mattering and the television was
empowered,
was sent a signal by this man that those
private thoughts could now be made
public.
As Donald Trump's candidacy unfolded,
he built and created a symbiotic
relationship with what we think of as a
vast decentralized social media army
that did his bidding during the
campaign.
These were mostly young white men on
platforms like reddit and four Chan.
And they develop this kind of culture of
competing with each other,
vying with each other to produce the
most creative,
the most sticky,
uh,
the most intrusive meme or message that
would penetrate social media and then
seep into the mainstream media.
So everyday they would do this and in
response to the events of the new cycle,
be it Hillary Clinton's latest comments
be at Donald Trump's latest policy
pronouncements.
They would go take that moment and
elevated the mainstream media would
generally confident that Hillary would
win the election.
She was ahead in the polls fairly
consistently and because she had much
higher favorables while both candidates
were unpopular,
Hillary's favorables in public opinion
polls were generally about 10 points
higher than Donald Trump's,
but the people doing social media
sentiment analysis firms like foresee
we're tracking and finding something
very different.
Their job is to track net sentiment on
social media.
I'm in connection to political debates.
And what they were finding throughout
the campaign was that while Donald
Trump's favorables,
we're about 10 points lower than
Hillary.
His net favorable it on social media was
about 10 points higher than Hillary.
One of the most striking facts we
discovered when researching this book
was that the day that Donald Trump had
the highest net favorability on social
media was his darkest day of the
campaign.
It was the day of the access Hollywood
tape being released,
and it was because at that day his
supporters who had such intensity of
commitment to him rallied around him.
They surged to his defense and even
though it seemed in the mainstream media
like this was the day that was all
losing for Donald Trump on social media
that day,
Donald trump actually won.
He was elected because he intuitively
understood what we call new power and
new power is this ability to harness the
energy of a connected crowd.
And while Hillary Clinton had a very
traditional relationship with her crowd,
Donald Trump had a relationship that
reflects what we now know you need to do
in order to really build depth of
commitment politically.
So the NRA understands intensity in the
same way that Donald trump does.
One of its great strengths is in
addition to its old power brand.
The fact that it's a feared institution
that politicians kind of quiver at the
thought of it also has an incredibly
powerful new power arm and that arm goes
beyond just its membership.
It actually has been very effective at
cultivating the most extreme elements of
its support base.
If you listen to an NRA ad now,
they actually don't really talk about
guns anymore.
They talk about this conspiratorial
worldview.
They pit liberals against people with
their values.
They suggest that government is on a
mission to take away people's liberties
and what they've learned is that the way
to keep intensity in their crowd,
the way therefore at moments that really
matter for it like the mansion to me,
Bill.
Well you remember when that bill came to
Congress after the newtown massacre,
90 percent of Americans supported
background checks in public opinion
polls.
Yet the 10 percent of people who oppose
them.
One,
and the reason I did was at that moment
the NRA was able to rally the intensity
of its supporters to a outnumber for gun
control forces eight to one in calls to
the key senators who were the swing
votes on that issue and the way they've
done that is not by reigning in their
supporters,
but actually unleashing their agency by
providing micro grants to small,
highly extreme political organizations
at the grassroots level all over the
country by supporting the commerce,
the culture,
the politics,
and the totalizing worldview of gun
rights supporters and in doing so,
they've actually been led by their
extremes,
but it's their extremes that are helping
them to keep the power that they have.
The question that those of us who want a
world that's different to the world that
Donald trump is building is how do we
stop him?
What will it take?
It won't be another candidate who is
marginally more favorable or popular
than Donald Trump,
but lacks the intensity,
that capacity to mobilize new power that
Donald Trump demonstrated.
It will need to be a candidate.
It will need to be a movement that has
real intensity behind it.
You know,
we think of those Parkland kids and to
me,
they're the hope because what they're
showing is they understand this need to
generate intensity.
They understand how to use new power.
They've got this intuitive understanding
that it's not enough just to be right.
It's not enough just to stretch out the
facts that you have to embody that
message in a way that means that if your
a,
your kid,
anywhere in the world,
you can take that,
adapt it,
make it your own.
These movements tend to be
decentralized.
They tend to not have strict messaging
associated with them and they tend to be
structured in such a way like the me
too.
Movement where you can take a frame,
adapted an agile boards.